when it comes to anti-heroes like rip
audiences can accept otherwise
unacceptable levels of violence since
they're Tethered to the narrative
throughout season 4 another beloved
character Lloyd Pierce has buted heads
with one of the other Ranch hands Walker
after Lloyd breaks the no fighting in
the bunk house rule in episode 4 rip and
John ultimately decide the two should
work their issues out by pounding the
crap out of one another rip not only
pummels Lloyd repeatedly in episode 4
after the latter's initial fight with
Walker but he also beats him down
aggressively in episode 6 and
graphically smashes Lloyd's hand with
boot when rip destroys his best friend's
hand it's because Lloyd refuses to back
down from a fight that John Dutton
ordered rip to have Lloyd and Walker
undertake until they could work out
their issues by the time rip nobly
shoulders the burden of taking Lloyd
down for good Lloyd's been continually
fist fighting with Walker for well over
an hour add to that the fact that Walker
and Lloyd's entire conflict does little
if anything to further the plot of the
series and you have the makings of a
scene that simply crosses one bridge to
many